Hey,
what's going on?
This fucking damn thing.
I,
you know,
I ordered this stupid part.
I swear to God.
I'm picking it up today.
God dammit.
Let me hold it onto it like a terrorist for the last time.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's spelled bird.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on you.
How the fuck was your Goddamn Christmas?
Why is this?
Why are all fucked up?
God fucking dammit.
I swear to Christ.
I said this was the last fucking time I was doing this.
Did Not,
isn't was what I said.
You know,
it's really fucking amazing.
Is the abilities for wires to just get off fucking how do you look at it?
It's like,
how did that happen?
How the fuck did this whole fucking thing go down like this?
The headphones.
The fucking headphones?
Yes.
All right.
Hang in there for fuck sakes.
Yeah.
You feel better because I'm losing my shit.
Does that make you feel better about your fucking cubicle dwell and fucking lie?
While.
I hope it does.
I hope it does because I'm all about the positive vibes in the two to the one
Nisi
20,
19.
Um,
how are you?
Did you have a
hey,
merry little Christmas.
Did you get through it without arguing?
I forgot to give you guys that pep top.
Don't take the fucking bait.
All right?
If one of your siblings is a Trump supporter or they're a fucking liberal Larry
or there centrist,
centrist Susan,
you know,
never picked the side.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ,
only fucking person.
And I know could meet a serial killer and be like,
wow,
I guess I can understand why you need to feed.
Oh yeah.
I rarely talk to me when you end up in a trunk,
Susan.
Um,
there's no reason to do that.
There's no reason to do it because you're,
you're not going to get what you want,
which is the satisfaction of the other person going,
oh my God,
I never realized how right you are.
It wasn't until you called me a closed minded fuck head that I just stopped and
paused and was like,
wait a minute,
am I close my [inaudible] am I [inaudible]
you have fucking believe what cat catered cognac.
Cosmetic FAC hair.
Yeah.
I'm Chris Smith.
It's like hell.
Hello.
Yeah.
Calling your stocking much.
You know what?
I fucking can't stand.
I can't stand when new speak comes out.
I get it.
Back in the day,
you know when we were cavemen walking around like,
Oh
uh Huh.
Doing that shit.
You know you had to come up with some fucking words
so you wouldn't like be asking for,
you know,
some water,
but yet sounded like you were joking.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
Aw Man.
It's the noises I make.
Um,
it's why I do it in my garage.
No one and
don't want to bother anybody.
No.
And I also understand it.
If something new comes along,
you know,
like can I iPod?
What were you supposed to call it?
A little stereo.
I don't fucking know.
Right.
I understand those words.
I just hate when new fucking words come around and then everybody just starts
fucking saying them.
It drives me up the fucking wall.
Especially like on Twitter when there's the new [inaudible] Instagram.
Yeah.
And they just come when they go.
Remember the for awhile,
like when you posted something,
someone will just go this,
you know?
And then what?
What's some other that's stupid shit out there.
I can't fucking stand.
Just drives me.
It's so fucking unoriginal.
I just,
I had somebody give me shit saying something I tweeted wasn't funny and they
used the Gif.
It's,
and I brought the guy back.
At least I'm fucking write my own jokes.
You fucking hack.
Someone had to like fucking think of a funny response to my unfunny joke for you
with a little video on it and now you feel like you're clever.
I,
I just drives me at the fuck.
You know,
I just got back into working out right.
Fucking if I hit one more fucking,
you know,
cause I've got those,
those TRX bands.
All right.
If I hear one more Douche,
tell me that I'm engaging my core.
You mean work in my abs.
You fake Tan cunt.
And what's great about these is you're always the one love balance.
You're always engaging your core,
you know,
board a plane anymore.
You expedite the boarding process.
Step back from what you gonna do.
Great.
You fucking waitress.
Um,
do you guys get that?
Put your jacket to the LV had me too.
We can expedite the boarding.
Bragg says,
do you want to sound like you have a fucking law degree?
Yeah.
Um,
you're on here for one fucking reason only and that's cheap airfare.
Yeah.
Stop acting like it was a dream.
I like to travel.
I like to wear a uniform.
Yeah.
I like to expedite the boarding process while engaging my core.
This hashtag shaking my head.
Yeah.
Let me ask you fucking Twitter concept question.
How Times have you hashtag shaking my head and you actually were shaking your
head.
Okay.
I'm trying to think.
Last time I fucking shook my head.
I actually probably do it a lot.
It's funny when I try to keep my,
my fucking cool while I'm driving.
It's fucking guy.
Oh my God.
These fucking assholes out here on,
on the highways,
the way they pass you on the right hand side,
it's unbelievable.
You can get into the left lane doing like 40 miles an hour.
You don't want to get off the highway.
You got to be doing like 120 and you watch them pass,
you're doing 80 and you look in their lane and there's a guy a quarter mile away
and they're gonna have to stop on the fucking brakes.
I think it's just psychologically psychological out here that,
that,
that there's so much traffic that you just think to yourself like,
you know,
anytime there's an open space,
you're like,
ah,
you just fucking florid.
Well,
maybe I'm just that do shoe has like the baby on board sign in his head.
I have no idea.
Um,
but speaking of cars,
my latest obsession,
if I was going to buy a car right now,
all right,
if I was a single man,
if I didn't have a child,
I had a full head of hair to flow in the breeze,
I would get the Porsche Targa the fast one.
All right.
In lava,
orange.
Just like my pubes.
Um,
cause I am a child of the 70s,
and she remember that Shit in Boogie nights when Phillip Seymour Hoffman rest
his soul is talking to mark Wahlberg's character.
Any,
any,
it says how the the corvette is in a competition.
Orange.
That was my favorite fucking detail.
Uh,
seventies detail competition.
Orange.
Oh,
either way he didn't have one.
He had,
he had a uh,
oh no.
Mark Wahlberg's character got the corvette and competition orange and then
Phillip Seymour Hoffman showed up with like a Datsun two 40 [inaudible] or
something.
It's still a decent car.
Right.
Um,
but it states no corvette.
anyways,
I got to see what that looks like cause I hope it's not a red orange.
I'd want an orange,
orange.
You know,
there's a lot of things right now it's just like,
I don't know,
everybody's got to start fucking with the colors.
But that thing and it's got the automatic fucking a rooftop and it was actually
Porsche enthusiastic who are engaging their core when they press the fucking
send button on the youtube comment.
We're complaining actually complaining.
The old one you had to,
you had to do it by hand and then fold up the cloth top and then put it in the
bonnet is they say overseas,
put it under the fucking hood.
Now this one you just push a button.
Yeah,
the backend lifts up a little bit and then the top fucking goes down like the ED
.
It's,
it's,
it's a fucking work of art and there's all these cuts,
right?
And like leave it to the Germans to take something really simple and make it a
fucking,
and what?
Make it fucking perfect.
So what was I goal?
I would be concerned if I were somebody could,
but behind me,
man,
that comes a good two feet up on the car.
Well they fucking pull up.
I'll put,
make,
make the tires,
do one rotation and then push your button.
I'm amazed that when they designed this,
are you amazed
the fuck are you ever designed?
Oh,
why am I in such a mood?
You know what,
I just,
I had a bad night's sleep.
I had this dream that I was,
I was playing the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
Massachusetts.
One of my favorite promoters out there,
Bill Bloomin',
Reich W he was in my dream and he was talking the way,
talk to him,
right bro?
I saw that article I wrote about your word.
You really said some mean things about Merck.
I was like,
are we talking about,
I would never say mean things about you.
I love you.
No,
just clown car came off a little moon.
So I felt like an asshole.
Like however I was joking about him,
somebody had came off his fucking main site,
apologized to him and then I'd go out on stage.
This was a stress dream cause I hadn't been on stage in like five fucking days
and I got this European tour coming up.
So I just booked myself with the comedy store starting last night,
right through Sunday.
Just going to do as much stage time as I can.
And I had a great set last night.
I Dunno.
It's just,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I just know I got to fucking,
I needed to do all these nights and then I'll then I'll be fine when I go to
Europe,
but whatever.
MMM.
So I go out on stage in my dream on the Wilbur theater and if for some reason
it's like six stories in the air,
six stories up and there's people way down below who clearly can't see me and I
feel like I have to walk to the edge of the stage,
but I don't want to fall down and I'm making fun of it and nobody's laughing.
I'm just bombing.
And for some reason I'm on eye level,
um,
with the six story balcony level and they're just staring at me and I'm not
doing well.
Yeah.
And then halfway through my set and there's all these obstructions to like,
I'm walking and all of a sudden I'm like behind some giant pole and nobody's
laughing.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
what the fuck am I doing?
At one point I was laying down on the stage crawling towards the edge cause it
was also really dark and I couldn't see how deep it went down.
I dropped the Mike down there,
somebody turned on a record player and I shut it off.
And it was just like,
hey,
slowed down.
Wasn't that song?
I don't know why I just picked that.
Maybe cause I'm a dancing monkey on stage.
I have no fucking idea.
And then halfway through it,
one of the few comics that I don't like in this business came fucking walking
out like the selfish cunt that he or she is and picked up like a little square
fridge that you'd have.
They've when you lived in like a studio apartment.
And I was like,
really?
And the person was like,
yeah,
really?
And they just fucking took and started walking out and I said the person's name,
I said from the bottom of my heart,
I fucking hate you.
And then I quickly shut up cause I knew everybody in the crowd was going to film
it.
Um,
and what's funny is as,
I don't really hate this person in real life,
I just fucking avoid them.
Yeah.
You know,
that's what a great thing about getting older.
As you stop hating people,
you just sort of like,
you avoid them.
Even if you're sitting next to you just mentally avoid them.
You just like,
okay,
I know who you are,
I know how you act and this is what I expect so I'm not going to get upset.
I'm just fucking not going to engage in it,
you know?
And uh,
and then somewhere along the line they turned the lights on and I realized that
I wasn't six stories in the air.
Yeah.
That the stage was still the same height it usually was.
And then all of a sudden the microphone worked and I could start,
you know,
doing my job and I started killing again.
So maybe the dream was built.
You have an irrational fear about taking four or five days off from standup.
I will tell you last night I fucking,
uh,
I went on stage and I got this new Bush,
Michelle Obama bit that was bombing,
you know,
cause she's so fucking precious.
You know what I mean?
I don't,
I don't know why,
out of all the first ladies,
every first lady has always been made fun of her for some fucking reason is like
off limits.
So,
you know,
as a comedian,
something is off limits.
I mean,
you know,
you kind of have to steer the ship towards it at one point,
just,
just for the fun of it.
Right.
So last night was the first night.
Okay.
Uh,
I started to get it,
I started to get it to work and um,
yeah,
I tried a another bit,
you know,
about this.
Does Gay kid,
you know,
parents didn't know she was gay and that parents work,
Willis bucket,
people that think you can pray away being gay.
Um,
what can you pray away?
Oh,
I went to church,
by the way.
I got there late,
you know,
I felt bad.
I got there,
register fucking guy was starting his homily and I was like,
oh fuck.
And then part of me was site because I didn't have to sit through the first two
readings.
MMM.
And uh,
they really switched up the words a lot.
The shit that you say,
they switched it up a lot.
I was like,
is this like some west coast thing?
My mother in law's like,
Nah,
they kind of changed it up,
you know,
he's be peace,
be with you and also with they like added a bunch of words like peace be with
you and I uh,
I concur that also and would wish that upon you to sir.
Slash ma'am,
you're going to say all out before you should fucking shake hands with somebody.
Um,
I dunno,
I hadn't been in church in a while.
I literally thought my suit was going to catch on fire when I walked in there.
Yeah.
Do we need to know?
You're a piece of shit.
You know,
you haven't been there in awhile.
You just walk in and you just thinking of all this shit God would be saying to
you if you really exist and you just walk in and going,
I know,
I know.
You know?
And then after,
while he gets stubborn and be like,
well,
you know,
Dude,
technically you made me so whatever my fucking flaws are,
I know you have this convenient excuse of the devil.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Hey,
you know I made you perfect,
but you listen to the devil.
Well didn't you make the devil toe
isn't all of this,
you're fucking grand scheme.
Right?
Okay.
I actually,
when I look at God that way,
right?
If he existed,
you know,
and it is a he.
Okay.
Because at the end of the day,
you know,
when you really look at the world,
most of the great things that were created were done by men.
I mean,
I don't know why I have to shy away from that and this progressive,
you know,
ladies,
why don't you put your fucking brains?
Will your mouth though and fucking start invents some shit.
And I know you're going to come at me with this fucking list that,
that is impressive to you.
But what I also want you to Google my feminist little friends is what have men
invented.
And you watch that fucking there.
It's fucking Dan Marino,
1984 48 touchdown,
5,800 fucking yards when you could still beat the shit out of a wide receiver
and a quarterback.
Um,
having said that,
I,
uh,
I respect,
love it and I feel you're very brave at a time you put out your lab coat ad set
out to make a new widget.
Okay.
And it's so much harder for a woman to put on a lab coat.
I'm just trying to make it sure.
I have it all down.
Um,
to someday I would like to host an awards show and I have to make sure that I'm
the fucking Zombie that they're looking for.
Um,
I'll do,
I'll come out and do a monologue just talking about how dumb men are and how we
can't even figure out how to dress ourselves without women.
You know,
all of that shit.
And they'll just fucking eat it up.
Uh,
that's another thing I fucking hate.
You know what I hate?
I hate when a co,
a running back gets like fucking 40 carries and he has like 47 yards and then he
finally breaks one for about 15,
and then he gets up and he does that.
I'm eating a bowl of oatmeal thing.
It's like,
buddy,
we've been feeding you the fucking ball,
all God damn game.
Once you go look at your fucking yardage average,
you're 2.7 yards per carry count.
Um,
yeah.
Hey Bill,
how about something positive?
All right,
I got something positive for you.
I watched this fucking Celtics first,
the Philadelphia 76 six,
you know,
fucking blew me away in that game.
Is that Joelle,
Joelle and beep.
So you say his name.
I'm not looking it up because I can't spell it.
Um,
evidently that guy played a soccer or football as they call it over the,
over the fucking sees there.
Um,
until late in his life.
I gotta tell you something.
That guy is like a ridiculous factor when he's on the court.
And I know he's one of the guys in the league,
but I don't,
I don't think,
uh,
I don't think he's getting the respect he deserves.
That fucking guy is a problem on both ends of the court.
Blocking shots,
getting rebound scoring points.
Fucking asis moves great for a big man.
Um,
I am praying to the basketball gods.
Look at me.
I'm going to church.
I'm,
I'm fucking all about every God out there now.
Yeah.
Um,
I can't,
you feel the,
the joy that's coming back into my life,
my life.
It's like the end of the Grinch,
isn't it?
Um,
I am praying to the basketball gods that the,
the,
uh,
that the Celtics in [inaudible] 76 or so are going to fucking play again.
Um,
I don't even care if we lose.
That's how much I enjoy that playoff series.
And back in the day when I used to watch Andrew,
Tony and Dr Jay,
Bobby Jones,
Billy Cunningham,
all those motherfuckers coming to town,
Daryl Dawkins the first time through,
and then it was Moses.
MMM.
Anyways,
the fuck was I just going to talk about,
oh,
I remember.
Oh,
so I'm reading this book on Bob Cousy and,
uh,
Bill Russell called the last pass.
Does that really count as reading by the way to read about sports?
I don't think it does.
It's like a long sports page as far as I'm concerned.
Um,
I don't know if I brought this up already.
I forget.
But like for the longest time I thought that the first
NBA basketball player with the sneaker deal was Michael Jordan.
Now he might've had wait his name on the sneaker,
but then I found out that those,
uh,
red and white converse,
we're called the doctor J's,
but the,
I don't remember them having his name on it initially.
So then,
um,
I'm reading this book
and I find out that Bob Cousy and likes 1962 or 63 had his own sneaker.
He signed a deal with pf flyers and it looks like a bootleg chuck Taylor.
And I found a pair on,
on fucking Ebay for 155 bucks.
I didn't buy them,
but because I'm not a sneaker head,
yo,
uh,
Yo,
you see the do Jordan 48.
Um,
what are they up to,
by the way?
What are they up to?
It is amazing that 30 years has gone by.
He must have a new sneaker every year.
I would say they're on the Jordan 32.
So let's look this,
well,
let's finish this story.
So Bob Cousy,
that's the one I want,
you know,
I'm kind of fascinated by that whole
mmm.
A sneaker culture as far as like,
you know,
all the different,
like do you get the Sundale three fours or whatever,
you know,
Jordan's 2019.
Let's see what they got coming up.
What do they got in the,
in the,
in the fuck it's sneaker barrel.
Air Jordan,
one retro sample.
Oh,
it was a sample sets.
Not exactly what they came out with.
And they want $4,000 for those.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What do you do?
How do,
what do you stick your head?
You,
you put them on the wall so you feel like you're always in a foot locker.
All right.
Air Jordan.
Release 2018.
All right,
let's see.
What are they up to here?
Air Jordan 12.
How the fuck are they?
Only on the 12th.
All right.
Air Jordan nine
dude [inaudible] sent me a text the other day was fucking hilarious.
He's like,
dude,
Jordan,
three MOCHA fucking over.
And it was the Jordan threes with this mocha color cement thing.
Hmm.
And I,
I fucking died laughing.
I mean he's,
he's like,
Jeez,
like that fucking chick there with the thin head Sarah Jessica Parker on sex in
the city.
So rather than talking about fucking high heels,
he's talking about sneakers.
Um,
anyways,
so Bob Cousy had a pair of pf flyers and you know,
with this,
with the little circle is on the chuck Taylor was his face and it said Bob Cousy
on it and they were black and they had a little green trim on them.
So that's as far back for all you fucking sneaker heads there.
I know Kareem Abdul Jabbar,
he had his own,
did he have his own sticker?
Ucla low top Adita I dunno,
but who was like the first guy actually had like his name on it though.
Cause I think maybe the technically,
yeah,
the doctor Jay Converse just said,
yeah.
Um,
we're just nicknamed the doctor J's,
but they said Congress,
let me see,
let me look that up,
doctor Jay.
Conversely,
this is why I like talking shit about things cause then I ended up getting into
it like fucking the pro,
the premier league.
MMM.
All right.
Let's see here.
Yeah,
those are the classic
classic converse all stars.
I don't see his name on it.
Oh.
And then eventually they did.
But the original one,
one of the clean his fucking shoes ever.
That for some reason
I think the newer ones.
So when I was a kid they didn't say dr j on him.
And now I'm looking at a really old pair and those ones say dr j.
So I think after a while they said doctor Jay and those things look like they
came up before the year Jordan.
But as far as I can tell the Bob fucking cozy the Koozie one stowed.
It was somebody's fucking way back to Guy Kool g ones with a pork pie hat
fucking over Shea.
Um,
all right,
let me look at some stuff here.
Uh,
I missed the last two Liverpool Games.
I get all wrapped up in the holidays and I cannot fucking believe this.
I don't know anything about the Wolverhampton Wanderers.
But somehow we lost to them.
Yeah,
we beat new castle United four to nothing but the fucking wolves.
These guys don't even look like they,
they're there.
There's nothing premiere about their,
their uniform,
their fucking name
or anything.
What happened?
Mohammed Silo and Virgil van Dutch struck to claim,
oh no,
they won.
Wait a minute.
That doesn't make any fucking sense.
Cause we beat Manchester United three to one and it says three to one and then
it says fucking zero two.
So I guess they do that all cause that was an away game.
Ah,
you cheeky cons.
All right,
I learned something else.
That's how they do it.
Okay.
So they got arson,
a one nil arsenal coming up.
The only one,
the only premier league game,
uh,
I've ever been to.
I told you they played Everton was fucking hilarious.
And they went up one to nothing and they started singing one nil arsenal in
halfway through the fucking Song Everton scored.
And this little blue puff of smoke came up,
the 40 Everton fans.
We're going fucking nuts.
And all the arsenal people that just shut the fuck up.
Uh,
I love when that happens.
I was watching a ranger game earlier this year and fucking as always,
Henrik Lundqvist was playing unbelievable and the whole garden is going and Rick
luck with Henrik Lundqvist or whatever,
and as they're chanting at the other team,
fucking scored.
Ah,
that's
switch you get.
All right.
Let's look at some Google news here.
We'll start with,
uh,
the greatest country in America,
the United States of America.
All right?
After Trump visits,
Iraq,
lawmakers demand US withdrawal.
Finally,
let's get the fuck out their way.
We're going bankrupt.
Iraqi lawmakers demand withdraw.
Baghdad,
Iraqi law makers.
This is the greatest thing that could fucking happen to us if we combine it with
solar power in electric cars.
All right?
You gotta hit him where it hurts.
Just like the feminists do.
The feminist go after the money.
They go after the advertisers.
This is what the fuck you gotta do in the Middle East.
All right?
Truly,
the great thing though is if we pull out,
I believe they'll just go back,
unfortunately,
because I don't have a problem with Middle Eastern people.
I just have a problem with cunts.
Okay.
And cuts,
they're everywhere.
Right?
As long as you're not a,
I don't have a problem with you.
So I think that they'll go back to trying to fucking,
you know,
deal with each other.
Hopefully not in a violent way,
but you know,
it's going to be.
But I always looked at it like the way when Russia withdrew from fucking Europe,
everybody was like,
okay,
where were we?
And they just picked up with their fights again.
It's really,
I,
for the life of me,
I'll never understand how war is legal.
MMM.
You know,
we sitting here like working on gender neutral bathrooms while war is still
legal.
I mean,
it's just fucking nuts.
You don't use,
I think it's because they,
they keep updating the war,
the,
uh,
the weapons.
So it seems modern,
you know,
but if you still went out there like the Braveheart days,
and there was,
you know,
two people standing on opposing hills and then they just ran down the hill
yelling,
ah,
just fucking met in the valley.
And they had those sticks with the fucking,
uh,
the,
the fucking cannon ball with the spikes coming out of it.
You know,
basically you're dressing a raider fan,
except you can actually hurt somebody.
You don't have the rubber points.
You wouldn't want to put somebody's eye out when you're intimidating somebody.
Raider fans.
Um,
all right.
So politicians
from both blocks of Iraq's divided parliament called for a vote to expel US
troops and promise to schedule an extraordinary session to the debate,
the matter.
Parliament.
I like that they'd taken control of their country.
Again,
parliament must clearly in urgently expresses view about the ongoing American
violations of Iraq's sovereignty.
Said Salaam,
I'll Shamira a lawmaker loyal to the populace cleric mock
Tada Al Satter through the fucking balls you have over there to be any sort of a
leader,
man.
I mean you're really,
I mean,
I hope what they're doing over there works because what we're doing is not
stopping terrorism.
Maybe it's stopping it from coming over here.
I don't fucking know,
but all I know is when I look at the ledger,
uh,
you know,
we're,
we're fucking bankrupt.
We just keep raising our amount of debt.
Why don't we fucking good back here?
Get back here.
Bring the fucking kids home.
All right.
Fucking get on.
Get into this electrical shit.
I don't give a shit if it hurts the environment more just so we can,
we can pay this shit off.
All right.
With the money we make from exporting all the weed that we're growing,
Huh?
The God damn it.
If I can figure out how to solve the world's problems,
kid somebody in a suit and tie door.
Uh,
all right,
let's see what's going on in Germany.
That's my first stop.
Germany army could recruit EU citizens.
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
It just,
Jeremy,
they really doing this again.
All right.
Slowly loading,
slowly,
slowly loading.
It is really bizarre how Europe,
if they're not unified
digit date,
just fucking,
they will start a world war,
you know?
And then,
then what do we get?
We get shit for border.
What's the worst thing we did?
We get fat.
Is that all we're doing a Nobel,
I think you're doing a little more than that in the world ad right?
Alright.
German army could recruit EU citizens seven years after Germany scrapped
conscription,
whatever the fuck that at its defense chief has said,
employing EU citizens is an option to fill expert posts.
Army General Inspector
Eberhardt Zorn
said the forces had to lock heads.
Sorry.
Lock look in all direction in times of lack of qualified personnel such as
doctors and it specialists.
Oh Wow.
Have they outsourced all this shit in their country to the armed forces have
been beset by years of underinvestment.
Germany aims to increase its military by 21,000 personnel by 2025 well,
what the fuck are they getting ready for?
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Ah Man.
You know,
this is why you don't read World News.
This is why you just sit around and you try and find a new sport that you can
get involved in.
All right,
let me,
let me do the one read here for this week.
All right.
And by the way,
my little thing for my headphones came.
I just have to go pick it up.
Um,
all right,
let's get over here.
Um,
by the way,
made it through Christmas.
What's up without Busan?
33 fucking days in 33 days in.
I'm going to go to
the Rose Bowl Ba and then I'm going to go on my tour and I am going to be
fucking ready.
Bay B a butcher box.
Yeah.
Everybody.
Butcher box delivers healthy 100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range.
Organic chicken and heritage.
Bread.
Pork.
The greatest pork chop I've ever cooked.
Yeah.
MMM.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets starts with the commitment to
raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics and hormones.
They rub their bellies before they murder them.
Cook with the peace of mind knowing you're eating holiday,
high quality meat,
grass fed and grass finished products.
These aren't pigs eat another fucking pigs like the goddamn animals in this
country.
They see it's choice you can make for your family.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
You can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
all right.
All be for the racist,
uh,
beef and chicken for somebody.
Every once in awhile we'll bang somebody outside their race.
Uh,
beef and pork old school,
a mixed box for the liberal
custom box for a,
the Dean del Rey,
right?
Dean del Ray likes all his shit.
Custom lets you choose your own cuts for Free Bacon and $20 off your first box.
Go to butcher box.com/burr and enter Promo Code Burger B,
U R R r right?
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all the,
uh,
have a great weekend.
You can't okay.
See you on Monday.
And uh,
I guess that's it.
You know,
try to get along with each other.
Everyone.
All right,
I'll see you.
[inaudible]
is
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 27th,
2010 the final Monday of 2010 Huh?
What are you going to do with it?
Huh?
Are you going to make this the greatest Monday you'd like?
Don't you hate when he goes fucking motivational speakers?
You sitting there,
you're trying to get motivated to not be a negative comment like myself.
Right?
And then this guy comes out,
you get,
you're getting all excited.
So fucking have something positive be said to you or what does the guy do?
He makes,
he gets you all nervous with this fucking ridiculous heightened sense of urgency
for just a regular fucking day.
This is Monday.
Think about that everybody.
This is Monday,
December 27th,
does anybody know what that means?
Well,
I mean there is no history.
Don't you hit?
That's the worst part too.
When they start acting like somebody else talk to you.
Damn.
Well John,
there's no historical,
uh,
are thingamajig for December 27th.
This is just a regular day.
Think about if everybody,
it's just a regular day.
Is this just a regular shirt and my just a regular person.
Is that how I'm going to live my life right there.
Fucking Bam.
Blow his fucking brains out,
right?
Dare say it wasn't a regular Monday.
You fucking Douche.
It was a Monday you died because no one wants to hear your current speech.
All right.
I think I've said cunt 58 times already.
Um,
anyways,
this December 27th,
two days after Christmas [inaudible] 72 mother fucking days into me not drinking
.
I can eat five more days,
four more days and I break my record for uh,
you know,
being sober.
I'm calling for a hundred days and uh,
it's good.
It's going good.
Oh yeah,
I'm having a great fucking time.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
anyways,
did you guys have yourself a merry little Christmas?
Do you have a good Christmas?
Did you get the things that you wanted?
Um,
I had a fucking awesome Christmas once I was able to finally relax cause uh,
people out there who do the road truckers,
other comedians,
lounge singers.
Actually lance singers don't travel that just stuck at that same fucking place.
You know,
like Jack Nicholson in the movie,
the shining just slowly going fucking crazy.
Playing hand ball off the wall of their red roof inn.
Fucking sweet.
Um,
yeah,
when you travel as much as I do,
uh,
your brain,
I dunno,
it can't slow down at the needs like four or five days to slow down and uh,
you can't sit down on a couch in a lay down on a bed for like,
at least I can feel like more than 10 minutes.
Your brain is just fucking go and go and go and go and go and,
and uh,
took me like four or five days and then I was finally able to relax and enjoy
the holiday.
I actually a,
I was so wound up from doing the road.
I actually wanted to be a,
wanted to be alone.
I don't even know.
I didn't want to be alone.
It's Christmas.
I don't want to be alone,
but I did.
I just didn't want to deal with any sort of,
uh,
people.
And I've discovered when you become an adult,
truly become an adult is a,
Christmas is not about you anymore.
It's about making sure everyone around you had a great Christmas.
And then after all the frenzy is sitting back and your enjoyment is that
everyone around you had a great Christmas.
And I finally figured that out this year.
And,
uh,
I became a jolly son of a bitch.
I really enjoyed my Christmas,
you know,
and I gotta admit on December 26 yesterday,
I went out and bought something that I wanted.
Um,
um,
gradually putting together a John Bonam fucking,
uh,
I don't know if I'm going
out as,
as him on Halloween or a fun fucking,
uh,
going to make a stupid youtube video.
I don't know what,
but I'm gradually putting together shit that looks like stuff that he wore and a
,
I can grow a beard,
I'll die at Brown.
We'll see what happens.
You know what I bought?
I bought his Adidas sneakers that he wore at the,
uh,
the Seattle concert
and you know,
you're a fucking John Bonam freak for those of you weren't in the music.
John Bonam is the greatest fucking drummer I overheard,
you know,
um,
just as far as the shit that I like,
I know you can say all the Max Roach and all those fucking guys.
Who Buddy rich.
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
All right.
But like stuff for the cons.
Who think Neil Peart is better than John Barnum?
All right.
And,
and if you think that you
are a monotone jackass,
um,
all alright.
But anyways,
yeah,
if you go on youtube and you look up a,
it's actually Moby Dick rare clip and it's him in Seattle.
And at that point they weren't calling it Moby Dick Anymore.
They were calling it,
uh,
I something I guess over the top because Robert Plant goes,
John Henry Barnum over the top and then they got like this,
this,
this 1970s,
uh,
what is it fucking technology where it goes over the top tap,
tap,
wait.
You know,
it's supposed to be like blowing people's minds.
And if you look at the arrogant way,
Robert Plant walks away from the mic.
You really want to throw something at the back of his bushy head.
But,
uh,
if you watch John Bonam play,
he's got a pair of,
I believe,
uh,
the Adidas dragons.
Huh?
Anybody old out there?
Remember that deed is dragons,
Adidas country,
uh,
the Adidas dragons.
So I have those and all I need is a pair of white fucking pants and they sell a
replica.
That tee shirt that he wore on the song remains the same.
So right there I got the fucking outfit.
Then I got to do is just get a wig and I'm good to go.
Uh,
maybe I'll do that for you guys next year.
I'll make a fucking off.
You know,
there'll be a riot.
I should do that and not say it's me and I'll,
I'll just put a youtube video up and it'd be John Bonam cover and I'll butcher
at one of his songs.
And you guys can all laugh at how bad people trash
for actually buying the entire outfit.
I'm not above it,
dude.
I am a total fucking music geek like that.
I will actually buy some.
Speaking of that,
I want to recommend a book here before I am.
I don't know if I've even said anything funny other than revealing how fucking
pathetic my personal life is.
Um,
what do I got here?
out of all the led Zeppelin books out there and there's a zillion of them and
they're all fucking ridiculous for the most part.
They always have them selling their soul to the devil and Jimmy Page muttering
some sort of a cult bullshit walking away.
Um,
you know,
and then fuck is sticking a flounder in some girls Twat,
which probably happened in Seattle.
I have no fucking idea.
But,
uh,
the best book that I have found on it is a,
it's called John Bonam,
the powerhouse behind led Zepplin and it's written by his brother,
Mick bottom.
And it says right on the back or is it on the inside cover?
Why he wrote the book?
He basically says,
if I can just paraphrase here,
why don't I just,
I'll,
I'll read you a little excerpt about 10 years ago.
This is from his brother,
um,
after,
oh,
actually,
Linda Barnum wrote this about 10 years ago after reading yet another load of
rubbish about his brother John.
My husband mic turned to me and said,
I should write a book about our kid,
if only to tell Zoe John's daughter what a great bloke or dad was.
And that the seeds of this book began to grow.
And it's,
fuck,
it's just a killer book.
It's very,
very little of it is actually about,
you know,
all the bullshit that those other books are about,
which is,
you know,
and then they went to this town and they drank this much and they did this and
they did that.
It's,
it's really,
uh,
him growing up with John and John being home in between the tours and,
it's fucking awesome.
I read it in like a day and a half,
two days.
But when do you expect that,
considering I basically expose myself to be like that chick who whacks Selena.
You know,
you know that fucking psycho.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
If John Bonham was alive,
would I be stalking him?
This is really getting creepy.
All right,
let's,
let's fucking plow ahead yet,
but I want to recommend that book.
All right.
And there's big words and lots of pages.
By big words,
I mean big font,
lots of pictures and um,
yeah,
definitely check it out.
Definitely check it out.
And a classic Englishman,
I can tell you that about John Bonam in that like most Englishman,
he looks like he never lifted a weight in his life.
Got that awful fish and chip torso yet continued to wear tight shirts right
through this career.
Never understand that.
You only see that you don't,
you do not see that here in America,
except with gay guys.
Gay guys will wear tight shirts no matter what shape they're ready.
That's not true.
They will actually,
if as long as they got a little peck action going on,
they don't give a fuck about their stomach.
You know that as long as that chest is out a little bit further than the
stomach,
they wear tight shirts too.
But I've been over to Europe and I'm telling you,
I've never seen it like you can never did a pushup and their fucking lives.
Those types of bodies.
You got that seventh grade chest and arms,
and then this fucking,
I just drank a keg of beer,
stomach it,
uh,
this,
you know,
this is like,
you know what it is?
This is like they,
they made it big before Elvis fucking died in Elvis is the first behind the
music as far as the rock star and all that to,
I know every guy,
he stole all the music from the Blues and Gospel Black Dudes.
You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm so sick of that stupid ass fucking argument.
He didn't,
he was influenced by him,
but because he's a different race,
they said he stole it.
It's such bullshit.
You know,
if you're black and you listen to a blues guy and you play blues,
you're carrying on a tradition.
But if you're white,
you do it.
You're stealing.
All right?
And if black dudes fucking still white music,
they're sampling.
It's bullshit.
It's all bullshit.
Nobody steal from anybody.
You're a year and being influenced so enough already with the fucking whining.
I'm so sick of fucking people bitching that this unfair business is unfair.
Yes.
Show businesses unfair life is unfair.
Oh really?
Did you write it?
And then you didn't get credit?
Well,
fucking welcome to the club.
I never wrote anything that you get credit for,
but I can tell you right now,
I have been a victim of some very creative math.
Yeah.
You know what bill,
here's your royalty checks.
Uh,
that's $4 and 98 cents.
Yeah.
We had a hundred grand worth of whiteout that we,
and we had to buy a new typewriter that costs us 30 grand,
you know,
and all that comes out of your fucking pocket.
Yeah.
It's been going on forever.
But the reason why I say,
uh,
Elvis is the original behind the music is because he's the first guy who got as
far as I can tell,
got lofted all the way up into the stratosphere.
And uh,
like everything he did now is just so fucking cliche,
but he was the first guy doing it so nobody could really see it,
you know?
And by the time he died as a drug dealer,
drug addicted fat,
fucking a toilet that was 77,
you know,
at which point,
sapling was approaching 30 years of age.
They were,
it was already too late.
Right.
Does that make any fucking sense?
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to justify,
and this is also before,
like John Bonam never would've got that if he was living today.
I,
I can,
I can't guarantee that it wouldn't be dead,
but he definitely would have like a 95% chance of not being dead because someone
would be like,
you know,
say you had a problem.
That'd be an intervention.
And then also when he got out of shape and he started getting the man tits there
,
they,
they fucking,
he would've got the shit teased out of him on youtube and just start a sheer
fucking humiliation.
Uh,
I think you would've done some setups,
but you never know.
He is European and they just really don't seem to be into physical fitness over
there.
This is coming from an American,
they're not obese,
but they are just some fleshy mushy sons of bitches over there.
Not all of them.
You get your occasional one,
but they'll the occasional one seems like the ones that are born that way.
You know,
like their dad was like a fucking shipbuilder and his dad was,
you know,
fucking worked with Thor or some shit.
You know what I mean?
On a fucking,
now what?
What am I talking about here?
Really?
People.
Huh?
13 minutes of absolute shit.
All right,
let's,
what are we going to talk about this week here?
Um,
oh,
you guys want to hear a story?
Because when,
here's story here.
Do you get,
you have to take,
do you actually have to work right now?
Does anybody know?
Does anybody working right now?
Does anybody have such a fucking Dick for a boss that he basically gave you new
year's Eve off and then Christmas Day off and now it's Monday.
Now you're back to work.
You know,
this is a really,
I don't know about you guys,
but this is one of the most depressing weeks of the year,
you know,
is
the week between Christmas and New Year's.
Once Christmas is over,
you know,
it's like you see the buildup of the tree.
First of all,
you get your Christmas tree and if you're like me,
everybody trashes the tree except for this guy here who writes me this letter.
Hey Bill,
fuck the haters.
Fuck the haters.
Your tree is awesome.
Your tree is a noble fir,
which is a far superior tree compared to those faggoty Douglas firs.
I love this guy.
Immediately.
Just those trees are gay.
Um,
anyways,
where the hell am I?
Yes,
they look a little sparse,
but there is actually room to hang the ornaments.
I like to joke that most people decorate their Christmas bushes by just throwing
shit at them and hoping for the best ever.
Notice all the ends of the branches of Douglas Firs are freshly cut.
A Douglas firs do not grow in a conical shape.
That means Christmas tree shape.
I guess they have to be trimmed in order to look like a tree because they
normally look like a bush.
Exactly.
That's why I never liked those fucking trees.
It looks like a shrub.
I've never seen a fucking tree look like a Christmas tree.
That's why,
and that's why I liked the tree that I bought because it looked like a fucking
tree.
Thank you sir.
Um,
he said,
have you ever seen how they prune these trees on the farm before they ship to
your local grocery store parking lot?
A dude would dude with a hedge clipper tied to his back at an angle,
goes up and down the rows of bushes and walks around each one,
cutting it into a Christmas tree shape.
Nobles aren't artificially shaped at all and grow to be symmetrical and
perfectly proportioned.
There you go.
So go fuck yourself.
They also had somebody else write me a letter saying I fuck all those people.
My,
uh,
my sister or somebody is a,
Ah,
fuck,
I wish I saved.
This is in,
in some sort of artistic design or something to like my Theresa.
You know what?
I'm a little ahead of the curve people you way,
you know what's going to happen.
One of these fucking emaciated celebrities is going to get one and then it's
going to become all the rage thing.
We wearing uggs with the fucking Santa Claus Thong,
right?
With a midriff showing be like Anna God.
Like oh my God,
this tree is like,
oh my God.
And they're going to be in US magazine and that's going to be it.
Matthew mcconaughey will be naked playing bongos and it'll all work out.
But your rule,
remember that you heard it here first.
You heard it here first.
I actually bought a fucking tree.
You guys bought shrubs.
All right,
so fuck you and your holiday.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah,
it's a really depressing week.
So many ways you go out and you buy the Goddamn tree so that you have the tree
and as the excitement of the smell of the tree,
it smells like Christmas.
All my God,
it's got to happen,
right?
It's that time of year.
We're going to actually get off the wheel for a second.
Joy,
the people around us,
hopefully,
you know.
And then what happened?
Then you decorate the tree.
He put a little skirt around it.
You dress up that little whore,
right?
You get even more excited that one app,
but you come on for work and one of your family members or the person you live
with has wrapped a couple of gifts putting in underneath.
This is the buildup,
right?
This is Elvis,
1954 right before he fucking,
you know,
and then what happens?
Couple more gifts.
So he puts on a fucking Christmas record,
your balls filled up,
just waiting to fucking for Christmas Day.
And then Christmas comes,
all right,
Elvis on the fucking Ed Sullivan show.
Everybody's going fucking crazy people opening gifts is fucking bitches
screaming outside your window.
You throw down a scarf at him.
Everything is fucking great.
And then just like that,
it's over.
It's fucking over.
You know,
you get drafted,
send you over to Jeremy.
I can't do this Elvis thing.
I don't fucking know him saying here.
You don't want,
I mean that is fucking over.
And then you look in at your tree,
you know,
still get the lights.
It still has to skirt,
but what happened?
All the gifts.
They're all God.
You know,
it's a couple of pieces of paper.
It's like they peaked.
It's like your favorite band.
They had those three awesome albums in a row and now they're about ready to
fucking spend their rest of their career trying to recapture those,
the,
the whatever the fuck they did in those three albums.
Right?
No,
that's it.
So over to say goodbye to everybody.
You start looking at your family members.
You see him there are a year older.
She makes you feel older.
Yeah.
No,
nothing's on TV.
All the TV people are on vacation.
This show in something on a loop.
Mtvs finally show fucking videos.
It gets quiet.
You sit back,
you reflect on what a nice Christmas it is,
but she just can't get over this feeling of this wave of depression that's
coming because you know it's about radius start all over again.
Another fucking year with this fucking job,
with that fucking Douche telling me what to do.
My fucking by fanny,
a fucking girlfriend or your wife or husband.
It's going to be another fucking year.
You know
the answer your fucking tree,
just reminding you of your God damn mortality because you're not,
you're not,
you're not fucking water in it the way you wanted it before Christmas.
You skip a few days,
branches start to droop.
Couples start to turn brown like the gray in your hair.
Look at this artistic little jaunt.
I'm on here,
you know,
and by the ta and then what's the worst is then you start walking down the
street,
going out to your car and what happens to body start piling up out there.
You see your first fucking Christmas tree,
that Bah humbug Douche bag across the street and throws the fucking thing out at
like one o'clock in the morning.
December 26th it's sitting out there,
right?
Lay It on its side like a fucking victim at the beginning of the first 48 you
know,
it's got one little piece at tinsel blowing in the wind cause the rest of it's
shit got snatched from around his fucking neck.
Just laying there dead is a fucking door nail.
Next day you come out,
there's two more.
Start driving down the work and you just see them all over the place.
Just being the positive,
you know,
like fucking former stars and boy bands just littering the fucking highway and
it's fucking over
fucking over.
So what do you do then?
You got what?
You got New Year's eve coming up the worst fucking holiday of the year.
You know,
New Year's Eve is for young people.
It's not for old people.
You know,
that's when you know,
you've hit a level of maturity is when you can go to bed at like 10 o'clock,
10:00 PM on New Year's eve and you didn't go out.
You didn't get drunk.
You stayed away from those fucking morons.
You know,
I'll tell you what's a great weekend to go out as the weekend after New Year's
eve and all those guys who,
people are still fucking hung over and they're still fucking sick,
you know,
from their overindulging cause they don't know how to drink.
Then you then you head out.
Like I'll tell you what's it,
you know,
it's gonna be a great night.
Uh,
what's,
what's new?
Is He Friday night?
You want to be a great night to go out drinking Monday night,
that my friends will be a great God damn night.
If you're an antisocial fucking prick like I am,
that's,
that's where you want to go.
Um,
oh hey.
Speaking of which,
listen to this shit.
Me and Paul Versey,
we're coming down to the wire here.
We're actually tied.
All right.
As of right before this weekend,
we are tied.
All right.
And I gotta tell you something.
This week I had a breakthrough in my gambling.
We pick four games a week.
Whoever wins it in the end,
it's only a hundred bucks,
but it's more just about the shit talk and during the year,
um,
so this year nobody has gone undefeated yet.
All right,
so you're talking 16 weeks of gambling,
32 weeks between the two of us.
Nobody has gone for no,
we've had a,
you know,
a number of three in ones,
but nobody has gone for it.
Oh.
And uh,
Paul Versey actually did the impossible.
What are we called,
the unthinkable and the unimaginable.
The unimaginable is going for no,
he did the unthinkable.
He went,
oh and for so this week I don't know what I was talking to one a knee,
his uncles and uh,
he was talking about going against public opinion and there was this whole new
website and shit about going against public opinion with your gambling.
And I decided to take a little bit of that.
All right,
cause this is,
this is what I realized,
the reason why I could never break through three in one and get to foreign
[inaudible] is because I kept picking people that I thought were going to win
every fucking game.
And I know that sounds crazy,
but to gamblers,
that makes sense.
You know,
when you don't have money on the game,
you can actually sit there and fucking,
you know,
just say,
you know what?
Not only do I think this team's going to cover the spread.
I think they're gonna win the fucking game.
But all of a sudden when you put money on it,
you alligator Armad and you just start,
you know,
you get too scared to take a fucking chance.
At least I did.
So this week I was like,
fuck it.
I'm taking a couple of chances here.
All right.
I went safe at first.
I picked Tampa over Seattle and their doctor's wearing fucking coaching staff
with Pete Carroll.
I said,
fuck it.
I'm going with Tampa now.
That was one that I was,
that was my plane.
It's safe.
Bet.
And I don't know.
I was looking at Washington and Jacksonville and I was like,
you know,
it's in Jacksonville.
Jacksonville is gonna win.
You know,
they're gonna win this game.
They're going to get the running game gum.
They're going to fucking run over.
They got fucking rex Grossman playing quarterback for Washington.
It's fucking over.
But I don't know why I got a it.
I get a feel and fucking Washington's going to win this game just because nobody
thinks they're going to.
So I said,
fuck it.
I bet on Washington,
you know.
And then continuing that line of thought
San Diego was going into Cincinnati.
Cincinnati is shit,
the bed the entire fucking year.
San Diego always plays well in December.
They're a heckle,
a heckle,
and Jeckle a fucking,
uh,
what do you call it?
Jekyll and Hyde.
Fucking a team.
And I said to hell with that.
I don't give a shit.
I'm going with Cincinnati.
And Lo and behold,
yours truly with three and o yesterday,
three and own Paul Versey went one and two.
We had the Sunday night game,
but it got fucking snowed out.
I am one game up on him.
I'm sorry we're not tied.
All right.
So I went through,
you know yesterday he went one and two.
So no matter what happens tonight,
you know,
if I lose my game,
he,
he wins his game.
I'm going to be up by two games with one week to go.
All right?
But if I win tonight and go foreign and over four,
no,
I will have done the unimaginable.
I've done it.
And who do you think I took tonight?
Who would you take?
The spread is two and a half falcons at home playing the saints.
Who Do you like?
12 and two is that what a,
is that what the Falcons are Matty ice at home?
Just given two and a half.
It's their fucking year.
I said fuck it.
I'm taking the saints.
It took the saints and the points would drew Brees sticking with that line of
thought of going against the playing it safe?
I think a,
I don't think the falcons had been tested yet this year.
Add a,
I just think that,
you know,
this is just going to be one of those things that happens to a team like this.
I still think they might be a year away from doing something huge and this is
one of these games where I just think they're going to get a wake up call.
Like okay,
we're good,
but we s we,
but like we're not like the saints that actually have gone through the whole
thing on one won the super bowl.
That's why I took the saints.
I'm looking to go for and own.
Paul Versey has got the now Tuesday night game.
He took the Minnesota Vikings getting 14 points and a,
I'm telling you if I go for no and he goes one and three,
I'll pick up three games.
I'll be up for games with one week to go and we pick four games.
All have to do is fucking win one game to Goddamn extra point.
It's a chip shot and I will get bragging rights for the entire fucking year and
I will really be excited about that.
And with that seal,
there you go for all these though,
all of you who are into the gambling aspects of my life and I wish that somebody
actually came up with this awesome theory,
um,
about sports.
Uh,
this guy says,
Bill,
I have,
I have a theory about sports that tends to piss people off,
especially women,
which makes me think I'm onto something
and it's got nothing to do with the unpredictability of sports.
I think he's this,
this is,
this theory is basically why people like sports.
He said it mainly applies,
um,
to team sports,
some individual sports too.
Okay.
So here it is.
It begins back in the day when armies were in the field waiting to go into
battle and armies objective was essentially to conquer foreign lands and rape
women in order to celebrate the glory of their race slash,
culture.
And they would train for battles by making up games.
These games were based around themes of land grabbing and raping.
In this theory,
the ball,
football,
basketball,
whatever represents the seed,
the goals,
either posts or a hoop or a net represents the opposing team's women symbolizing
either their legs up in the air or they're vag or their womb,
whatever.
The opposing team represents the enemy army.
And the objective of the game is to get your seed,
pass the opposition and impregnate their women.
That's essentially the theory and it's a abridged version and it's why some
sports are like cracked and some are just who gives a shit when a sport is put
together.
Right.
It's a primal source of highly addictive goodness.
Did you ever think somebody who would like basically compare sports to rape with
then,
you know,
if you were going to do that,
you wouldn't think that they would basically then just say yeah.
And it's,
you think that they would be trashing it?
Not saying that it's a,
that it's a form of highly addictive goodness.
So there you go.
I actually liked that theory.
I believe in that.
All that subliminal Shit,
you know,
and uh,
yeah,
I'll go with deck.
What do you guys think about that dairy.
Am I the worst?
MERV Griffin ever.
I have no studio audience.
What do you guys think into the abyss?
Um,
am I really going to do another fuck?
I got it.
I got to be a,
I gotta be balanced here.
Fair and balanced when it comes to the sports shit cause it's becoming too much
sports.
I got to,
Oh,
here's one for you,
but I tell you,
I was,
I said I forgot I was going to tell you a story here.
Uh,
I took cleo out and we went outside for walks if she could do her business and
I'm walking up the street and I went around the corner and Cleo is a,
you know,
she's going number one,
she's taking a piss.
So I'm standing there right?
And I looked and I see this guy as cleos beginning to do her thing is walking to
his SUV,
like one of those little mini ones,
like the Lexus sort of one.
And I see him looking at me.
I just sort of look back and didn't think anything of it and cleos go in the
bathroom and I'm going,
that's a go girl.
Who's your good girl?
Go girl.
You go to bat boy as you go girl.
I'm doing that shit right.
Slapping her on her fucking muscular thighs and you know,
she finishes does a Little Harlem shake,
you know,
and then she fought.
We start fucking uh,
walking up the street and then I said,
the guy down at the SUV,
he all of a sudden I just say this,
pick it up,
dude.
I'm like,
what?
Cause Dude pick it up.
I go and I realized he touched,
she took a shit,
which she didn't.
I go,
she went number one,
I can't believe I said that,
but I wanted to win the argument.
I would be like,
she took a piss and when she went number one
and then the guy just gets in his fucking car such as getting this,
it is a little SUV thing.
I go,
what?
No,
sorry,
you go.
So I said sorry.
Yeah,
not as loud as you said that other shit.
Then he got in his car and he fucking drove away.
That's one thing I fucking hate about the west coast is the way they,
they confront you.
The confrontation out here.
I don't know why they do it like back east.
They would have been like,
hey dude,
fucking Nino.
Pick up your shit.
You know,
out here until he's like,
I don't know what it is they was calling you bro.
Hey Bro,
what's up dude?
Pick it up dude.
That is fucking annoys the shit out of me.
It just fucking annoying.
I don't know.
That's the only time it really bugs me being out here is that,
that that surfer fucking way that they talk when they think they confront you
bro.
What a Douche and you know,
what kills is that that affected,
that affected me the way I interacted with people,
you know,
for like the next four hours.
I just had that playing in a loop in my head.
Pick it up.
G was in my fucking head.
Everywhere I went,
you want paper or plastic,
you know,
just it's,
follow me or pick it up.
Deed.
I'm just fucking here in that in my head.
And uh,
what did you know what I mean?
The proper way to do that is just to be like,
excuse me.
Did,
did your dog just a go number two and like,
no,
no.
She went number one.
It'd be like,
okay,
I'm sorry.
It's just lightly people and leaving.
Okay.
That's the way you do it.
You know,
just go pick it up dude.
Fuck it.
Ah,
I wish I could train cleo know for those of you new to my podcast,
she is a pit bull to just do a mock charge.
You know they do that in the wild.
I just wish that just teeth are just fucking run.
Just have that guy p his slacks a little bit and then right to the point where
he thought he was going to get his fucking balls ripped off.
She just stops on a dime.
It turns around in,
this fucking runs up the beautiful way that she runs.
I should take a video of my dog run full speed.
It's one of the most beautiful things you ever going to see.
It's literally,
you could make like one of those secretary movies,
this fucking dog,
she is shredded
I and like she should,
she's awesome and way she runs the level of power,
first of all when she runs she gets like excited right before she does and she
does this move was she sort of throws her head back a little bit and just throws
her cell phone.
It's like,
it's like a fucking muscle car.
It's unbelievable.
Absolutely love watching her run.
And if I could just somehow train her to run and scare the shit out of people
who say pick it up,
deed with that would really make me happy.
So uh,
that's what happened this week.
And then I went inside and that ended up getting into an argument with Nia cause
I was just in a bad fucking mood.
Um,
no did I know she got mad at me about something else.
She was really pissed at me this week.
I don't,
what the fuck,
you know,
one of those deals.
I think it was,
cause I was coming down off being off the on the road and she thought that I was
going to be a dick.
And uh,
no matter how many times I tell her that I have to,
you know,
I need a few days to unwind.
Like I literally have the urge when I'm in the house to get up and just get in
the car and just start driving around because I'm so in travel mode and go and
go and go and go and go with that.
It,
uh,
it takes a fucking minute.
So,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know if I've got to do yoga or whatever,
the fucking idea.
It's definitely seems to be causing a rift.
Um,
but anyways,
I just remembered I was going to tell you,
oh,
I know last night I went and I saw the fighter starring Mark Wahlberg and a
Christian Bale and I can't recommend that movie highly enough.
That movie was fucking awesome.
It was a movie I wasn't going to see.
I'm like,
Oh God,
here we go.
Rocky all over again.
But what saved it was,
it was Micky ward.
And,
uh,
I remember his fights and I'm,
I'm embarrassed to say I didn't see that Arturo Gotti fight until years
afterwards.
I actually watched it on Youtube and I remember Colin Quinn coming into the
cellar raving about that fight.
Um,
in fact,
there's two fights that I remember that I was just like,
I have to see this fight.
It was the Micky ward,
Arturo Gotti fight after hearing Collin Quinn rave about it down at the comedy
cellar and,
uh,
the Diego Cra,
a corral is fight.
Uh,
was it corrals Casteel fight?
Is that so it was,
yes.
Diego,
I can't fucking remember.
She can tell.
I,
I dip in and out of boxing,
but uh,
that's a crap corrals.
Casteel their first fucking fight is unbelievable.
And Charlie Murphy flipped out about that when he told me he almost broke his
foot
at the end of that fight.
Well,
one of them is just,
you know,
knocked out,
gets up in this training goes,
you better fucking get inside now.
Cause evident.
I think I told this story before you,
cause you better fucking get inside now.
And he put his mouthpiece in him and uh,
he turned around,
they continue the round,
he fucking knocks.
The other guy technically knocks out the other fucking guy.
And I guess that got Charlie so fucking amped up.
He,
he stomped his foot down on the floor and woke up his whole family.
So those are the two fights.
But anyways,
this,
so this fight,
uh,
this,
this movie is about a Micky Ward's,
uh,
you know,
ascension up to trying to win a championship.
And,
uh,
I have to tell you,
man,
it is absolutely phenomenal.
I was rooting for like the Mark Walberg character while he was fighting.
It was fucking awesome.
Maybe want to get in great shape.
And I gotta tell you,
I don't think I've ever seen a movie where they did the Boston accent better.
Even just for that reason.
Even if you're not a sports fan,
you gotta go see there and see the five women that play,
his sister's stiff.
They're fucking unbelievable.
And it reminded me of this period in my life when I was underage and I used to
go out to these dive bars in like Chelsea and all those awful m towns north of
Boston,
Malden,
Medford,
rev.
I used to go out to all of those places because they didn't give a fuck cause
most of them were actually,
you know,
people were doing coke,
it was the 80s now some people was selling coke.
So like alcohol just seemed like it was a joke.
It's like somebody went up there and asked for some juice so I could actually
get with my fucking 12 year old boy ish face.
And um,
those five women that you see,
uh,
in,
in the,
in that movie that those are the kinds of girls that you ran into.
They will like 21 years old and they look like they were 40.
They already had a kid and they were jaded.
I can't explain it.
And so fucked up was,
it was a,
it was like a 20,
25 minute ride from where I lived,
which was a world away with no traffic.
Of course with traffic,
it took like a fucking hour to get there.
But uh,
yeah,
I just remember shooting the shit with them and they'd be,
oh,
you like smack.
But anyways,
those are my two recommendations for this week.
Get,
uh,
get the book John Bond on the powerhouse behind led Zeppelin by Mick Barnum and,
go see the fighter.
I'm going to see true grit this week and it's,
someone's trying to talk me into going to see Toronto,
but I,
I just,
I could give a shit about science fiction.
I've never been into it.
I never liked star trek.
I,
I liked star wars for maybe six months in my youth just because everybody else
liked it and I wanted to fit in.
So I kinda got into by just,
I don't give a shit.
I think those movies are gay.
They're gay.
All right there.
I said it all right.
You know,
you've put on the after burners.
I'm doing the best.
I can't hit warp speed and their stupid fucking handshakes and,
and the,
the aliens that they're friends with and the gay names of the fucking space
ships that they ride around in and it's just,
it's,
it's for nerds.
It's for people who don't know how to get laid.
I don't know.
That's not true,
but it just,
the stereotype is true.
And speaking of which,
I wanted to read this,
this overrated for this week when,
um,
this just reminded me of this.
Somebody wrote overrated Las Vegas.
Somebody wrote a,
I'm tired of everybody going to Las Vegas all the time.
They throw that shit around.
Like they're going like they're getting a free trip to a space station.
Like,
Yo,
anybody want to go to Vegas this weekend?
Like it's just the wildest,
craziest place.
It's not Vegas fucking stinks.
It's really not that big a deal there.
It's too hot.
The drive sucks.
How do they not widen out that 14?
It's actually the 15th or whatever to be more than two lanes.
Yeah,
that's the highway.
When you come back on Sunday,
it's a fucking nightmare.
Always flying to Vegas.
Never drive unless you plan on leaving at two in the fucking morning.
He said,
uh,
the other big thing I'm tired of with Vegas is the media perception.
That is the craziest place on earth that you never know what kind of nutty shit
is going on.
And it's like that every day of the year.
You should just go wild there.
Go home with three strippers,
party like crazy with your boys and wake up with the most insane story ever.
It's like that movie,
the hangover.
It's like that Song Waking Up in Vegas from Katy Perry.
Woo Hoo.
Yay.
Let's go crazy.
Um,
well I'm sorry to burst your bubble.
That doesn't really happen there folks.
The fifties and sixties or over,
not much that that's hip and happening goes on there.
Uh,
you don't see Sinatra and dean coming out to deal blackjack and drink with the
common folk unless you're bringing in six,
a six figure salary.
It's actually pretty mundane.
It's mostly full of sad old people blowing their social security,
social security checks on slot machines and shit and lousy food and ugly
tourists with their stupid kids place.
The places like Disneyland with gambling and God help you.
If you wake up with a hangover,
it's generally 117 fucking degrees out.
You walk out of your hotel and go,
Ha,
Vegas is not supposed to be.
It's supposed to be this out of control party place.
It's not.
You want a story?
Give Charles Manson a tab of acid and a meat cleaver and let them loose on the
strip on a Friday night.
You'll have a crazy Vegas story.
Fuck that place.
All right,
well sir,
I 100% agree and disagree all at the same time.
See,
what you did is you went there and you just looked at what you saw like I did
the first time I went there,
I walked there and I was all dressed up to do my shows like I was going to be in
the fucking rat pack and I saw all these fucking fat tourists with their flip
flops and going,
wow,
Vegas is dead.
It isn't.
You just don't know where to look.
First of all,
you ever see those pretty girls play in slots,
you know and you're like,
why is that?
Pretty girl all by herself playing slots.
How come she doesn't have a boyfriend?
That's because she's a hooker,
sir.
You want to have your crazy fucking day.
You go right there that you like me.
First Time we went to Vegas,
I thought a hooker was,
you know,
standing on a street corner snapping her gum.
Hey,
like that was a hooker.
All right.
But no,
they,
they're not supposed to be in the casino,
but they look the other way.
All right.
And I was actually at a bar one time and Jimmy Dore told an arm sitting there
hitting on this girl.
And Bill Jimmy finally came up and goes,
Bill,
what the fuck are you doing?
And I was like,
what?
This girl's hot.
He goes,
dude,
you're hitting on a hooker.
And I was like,
she's a hooker.
And he goes,
yes.
And then all of a sudden it was like the Matrix.
I could see it.
And then I went,
oh,
she's a hooker.
There's a hooker,
there's a regular girl,
regular girl hooker.
And you all of a sudden you can fucking see it.
Your problem is you don't know how to see it yet,
but it this way.
I just did a road gig with somebody and he told me a story.
He went to Vegas,
he won nine grand,
walked up to one of those girls,
said,
hey,
come here.
And she stopped playing slots,
walked right over to him.
He goes,
I want another girl like you,
uh,
to suck my dick.
Come up to room a whatever,
10 52.
And they did and they came up there and they were gorgeous and they sucked his
dick and he came on their face any one nine grand that night.
So there you go.
It is a crazy,
awesome fucking place where shit can happen if you indulge.
All right,
if you stand back like a fucking,
you know,
just shitting all over the place.
The,
yeah,
you're not going to have a good fucking time.
It is cheesy.
It is awful.
Um,
there are a bunch of,
you know,
they got malls there now.
They try to appeal the families.
All of that shit definitely goes on that,
but believe me.
All right.
I mean,
I don't think you can go to Fox woods and just go,
hey,
you and you,
I mean,
I'd give them,
probably do it,
but they're going to be old ladies.
Um,
and even there,
I'm sure they have their hookers.
All right,
but of course they do.
But I'm telling you,
go there next time you go there.
All right.
Just look for those pretty girls playing slots
and you will have an,
all of a sudden Vegas will become,
they just can't show.
They can't show that in the commercial.
You know what was that Fox?
The Fox was on that too bad baby does suck my fucking Dick.
You remember that corner?
I forget how it goes.
That whole thing about being at Foxwoods,
like it's this crazy thing.
You can't show somebody when nine,
you can show that then winning nine grand,
but you can't show that other part where he goes,
hey,
you find another one just like you who's dad didn't stick around.
So now you suck Dick for living.
Get another one of those.
Come back to my room and then end the commercial.
Bang.
Boom,
Sao was,
he fucking comes on their faces.
Okay.
You're supposed to read between the lines.
All right.
So when I would do is I would stop going to Vegas with the fucking nerds that
you go into Vegas with.
You know,
I mean you're,
you're going to Vegas,
dude.
You're trying to solve the transportation problem.
You're talking about the highways.
You're not looking at the right shit,
you know?
Yes.
Frank and dean are not going to be dealing poke.
Yeah,
they're dead.
They're dead.
Okay.
Yes.
Move on.
Ashton Kutcher's going to be their dress like James Bond taking.
I fucking hate those commercials.
I envy that guy's career.
You know,
I really envy that guy's career.
He's smart,
son of a bitch.
Most people do a hit fucking sitcoms and then that's it.
He got into producing very smart guy.
But I hate those fucking commercials with him sitting there with the stupid
cameras and everybody's just enameled with him.
Look at the guy with the camera.
Wait,
we all have cameras and one in our phone.
This really isn't that exciting.
Um,
so there you go.
Serve.
I know I trashed you,
but go to Vegas again.
Okay.
Fucking pony up the fucking 70 bucks and fly out there on southwest.
Go down to the strip.
Okay,
gamble.
Hopefully you win.
If you don't,
you know,
even if you don't just save a little money and have a cup of girls blow you cum
on their face,
I'm guaranteeing you,
you're going to go home with a smile even if you have to sit in that traffic on
the 15.
Hey listen,
I know there's a lot of people listen to this podcast and went to Vegas.
I want to hear some stories and don't make them up.
All right?
I want to hear some actual goddamn stories.
Okay?
And I'll see through the bullshit ones.
Unless you're a really good storyteller.
Okay?
Because the truth is in the details.
Uh,
look at me talking shit like fucking Rex Ryan.
Oh wait a minute.
Did the jets lose again this week?
Oh isn't that funny?
Isn't that funny?
It's almost like exactly what I said was gonna happen.
Fucking happened.
You know.
And I know a lot of you guys,
you probably can't remember cause you know,
you know,
nobody can remember shit in this country.
Like I used to do a bit about that Geico Lizard.
Oh,
you know everybody loves that fucking thing.
And I just look at that thing like that thing has no credibility whatsoever.
When those commercials started out,
he's like,
no,
I'm a Gecko.
All right,
get away from me.
Fuck you and your insurance company.
Then all of a sudden he like fucking sold out.
Now he sells the insurance and no one calls him on the bullshit.
Well this is my fucking a Geico Gecko lizard moment.
Here's Rex Ryan.
I play two clips.
This is rex Ryan on hard knocks back in August.
Let's hear what he has to say about his football team,
which started my hatred of the fucking jets.
Here we go,
everybody.
Let's turn up the volume.
Here we go.
If we play
this fucking league playing at their best.
So who's it on?
Whose shoulders as involved?
There you go.
Could you hear that?
Sorry.
How did I just fucked with the volume here?
Ready to crank that up.
All right.
That's what he said.
We were beat every team.
We play it up.
Beds.
We could beat every fucking team and his fucking league.
You know the usual bullshit.
Okay.
For those of you who forgot,
all right,
now here's him yesterday when they backed into the fucking playoffs like they
did last year.
Here we go.
You fucking,
yeah.
What happened?
Rex fucking dope.
I swear to God was was I was.
There's no reason for me to even bring it up,
but I have to bring it up.
Okay.
That's the second major thing that I was right about in football this year.
And as much as you fucking hate to admit it,
you know I'm right.
I told you Peyton manning was fucking overrated.
I told you he was a regular season statistical juggernaut.
He threw a pick six to lose the fucking super bowl and he has yet to get shit
for it yet to get shit for it.
It's fucking volume is way too high.
I'm sorry,
let me bring this down here.
He is yet to get shit for it.
All right,
and I told you I don't,
I didn't understand what the jets were talking about.
I didn't understand why they felt like they were the shit.
You know,
was it last year that they made the playoffs because the sat half their fucking
team wasn't it wasn't it?
That wasn't last year,
isn't that how they got into the fucking playoffs?
Then this year they come and just talk and all this shit and I look,
I'm not saying that they couldn't go on any team in the NFL at this point.
If you get hot in the end of December,
you can actually go on a run and when the fucking super bowl like the giant
stick.
All right,
that's another fucking hilarious thing.
The giants losing again this week and now they're questioning whether Tom
Kauflin is worthy to coach that team.
That team that Amir two fucking years ago or three years ago beat an undefeated
team.
14 point underdogs.
What did it,
did the game suddenly pass Tom Kauflin by at two and a half fucking years.
New York.
This is a difference between New York and Boston.
Boston Jay is completely 100% negative and they'll give you a little bit of
positive in the second they see negative,
they'd like the curses back.
They're awful that way.
But New York,
they kind of do the ESPN thing where they hype shit through the roof
and say this is going to be the greatest fucking thing ever.
And then when it doesn't happen,
then they go the exact opposite way.
And then,
then,
and then just somebody is the worst fucking thing that ever happened to the
Goddamn sport.
And that's why mediocre guys like Mark Sanchez,
who never really did anything in fucking college foot.
What did he do?
He won the fucking Rosebowl with that team that had won the national
championship.
I know there's a turnover of players,
but give me a break.
Matt Lionheart did more than that fucking guy and he's not even in football
anymore.
I think he's playing in like the fucking CFF CFL.
Right.
So there you go.
People,
but I will tell you this,
I uh,
I do back Rex Ryan on his foot fetish video.
I don't think there's anything fucking wrong with that.
He's got a foot fetish.
He made a video.
I totally agree with him.
It is a private matter and uh,
you know,
the guy loves his wife.
That's what I got out of it.
I didn't think he was a Weirdo.
I think that was just one of those classic fucking examples of every yet buddy
out there throwing sticks and stones and all this fucking shit when we all have
these skeletons in our,
in our closet.
Huh?
Does anybody else want to turn over their fucking hard drive,
their computer hard drive and let the FBI go through it and look at all the
fucked up shit that you've looked at on the internet?
Give me a fucking break.
I'm a freak just like him.
I'm not into feet.
You know,
some of the horrific shit that I've looked at on the Internet,
I'm going to fucking judge this guy.
Then the end they,
he kissed,
kept going.
It's a personal matter.
I'm not going to talk about it.
You're gonna ask me 16 ways to Sunday.
It's a personal matter.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's exactly right,
rex.
It's exactly fucking right.
It's your own fucking life.
It's a personal matter.
I'm not talking about it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I don't give a shit that it's on the Internet.
It's none of your goddamn business.
Watch the video if you want.
I don't give a fuck.
Then they go,
can you please talk about your wife?
And he goes,
yeah,
what can I say?
I've been with him for 23 years.
I love her.
She's awesome.
I was like,
you know what?
This guy's a great dude.
And I realized that I was wrong saying that he was going to make an attempt on
his life one day because he has,
because he has a great woman in his life and that's,
that's what's holding that man together.
And uh,
told you,
told you once,
psycho can spot another psycho from across the room.
So God bless Rex Ryan and his fucking foot fetish.
23 years.
He still fucking got the hots for his wife.
Make it freaky videos about that.
That was the shit gave me hope.
That's what it did.
It gave me hope.
I don't think that guy's a freak at all.
And that's like that tiger woods shit.
And everybody sat there judging him.
P people are full of shit.
You know,
just listen to that quiet voice in the back of your head that's calling you a
hypocrite.
When?
When you're at the dinner party trash and tiger woods,
you know,
when you think of some of the shit that you've,
you know that you rubbed one out to your wife's sister.
Huh?
What if that ever got,
I wonder if there was fucking video of that.
You fucking cheap fucking rubber went out to your wife's fucking sister and we
could see the fucking video that's playing in your goddamn head.
Really.
You're going to judge this guy cause he's into feet.
I don't judge him for that Shit.
I do judge them for being a shit talking jackass who sounds like one of my more
on buddies that have fucking sports bar.
I will trash him for that.
So with that,
who do you guys think is going to win the Superbowl?
Because I for one have no fucking idea.
I have no faith in my team.
I don't even know who they are already more.
They'll let my patriots,
they're like a drug addict,
you know,
are they clean?
Are they cleaned this week?
And they're going to play,
they're going to play fucking defense.
Are they?
They just gonna uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
And I don't like that,
that we basically should have lost to the fucking packers.
Uh,
but Aaron Rodgers was out and even then,
we still should have fucking lost,
but they didn't manage the clock.
Right.
And,
uh,
you know,
we lost to the jets once.
Jets could come in and beat us.
They could still come in and beat us in our own fucking place.
I mean,
that's still kind of way football is right now.
So,
which is why I don't understand the whole rex Ryan shit-talking that's what it
was about.
So there you go.
Let's see.
Let's move on to something else here.
Let's go with advice.
Uh,
Bill.
Hey,
I just want to write you and say I got let it go for Christmas.
Um,
I really needed it to,
my girlfriend dumped me on Christmas Eve.
Uh,
so you know,
my Christmas suck,
but your DVD really helped me out a lot last night.
I know what you say about breakups,
six weeks of pain and then it gets easier.
I said we were together for nine months and out of the blue on Christmas Eve,
she called me up and said she needed time for herself and her daughter.
That makes it tough too.
I got really close to her kid.
Here's my question.
What's the worst breakup you've ever had?
And have you ever,
have you ever been dumped over the holidays?
All right.
There's a number of things going on here,
sir.
First of all,
uh,
that's a real honest move on her part.
You know,
that whole fucking thing where you just go through a Christmas cause you don't
want to hurt somebody's feelings.
You know,
it's,
there's no good time for a break if she just could not go through the phoniness
of celebrating Christmas with you when she knew she was going to fucking drop,
the other shoe of that fucking expression goes.
So I gotta give her props for being fucking honest.
But,
uh,
and then also do you know you can do better than hooking up with some chick who
already has a kid?
And I hate to be mean.
I'm not trying to trash women out there who have fucking kids and they're single
and that type of shit,
but I'm trying to give this guy something positive,
all right?
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
you got it.
You got it down to just six weeks.
It's going to suck.
This is what you want to do.
Just go to the gym,
go to the fucking shit.
This is what women do.
Women fucking cry it out with their friends.
They get out of this system and then they go to the fucking gym and the next
time you run into them,
they want you to have that moment.
Why the fuck did I dump you when guys,
we never do that.
What do we do?
We get fucking drunk,
get a big fat fucking John Travolta head and then go out and try to bang some
skank at three in the morning.
Don't do that to yourself,
all right?
Just know it's going to hurt and fucking,
you know,
go spoon with your pillow and cry it out and then go to the fucking gym.
Put on some music that's gonna motivate you.
Go see that movie the fighter.
All right,
go get fucking motivated.
W do that shit.
And then,
uh,
then just go out and just start hitting on chicks that are completely way out of
your fucking leak.
And uh,
you know,
just go talk some shit.
And then he got the out.
I'm not ready to be in a relationship I got broken up with on Christmas fucking
eve.
I'm not even trying to talk to women.
You do that.
You fucking do the reverse sell you packing up,
they're walking towards your deck.
That's how you do it.
You know,
you'll get a sympathy blow job or something.
Just open your fucking mouth.
Don't be negative.
Keep them fucking laugh and spin a couple of plates.
Something will happen for your next thing.
You know,
it'd be like,
Wow,
dad,
that I almost get involved with the fuck [inaudible] was thinking about getting
married to some woman already had a fucking kid.
You know,
who's never really going to consider you her dad.
It's gonna have a bunch of issues and a dad's not going to be around when,
when her daughter goes through her her slot years cause she's trying to find
another father figure.
You don't want to be around for that shit.
You did.
All right.
So anyways,
he said,
here's my question.
What's the worst breakup you've ever had and have you ever been dumped over the
holidays?
Uh,
worst breakup I ever had was I
broke up with this girl who then ended up stalking me.
She told me she was pregnant.
Uh,
I believed her.
I got back into her life and then obviously I've realized,
you know,
when she was never showing that she wasn't pregnant.
Yeah,
I had one of those,
just a complete fucking psycho stocked me at my day job and all that.
She was a fucking nightmare.
Um,
had one those and have ever been dumped over the holidays.
No,
I haven't.
I've mainly been the person,
uh,
that's dumped people.
But I did get dumped,
uh,
the fuck did I get dumped?
It was in a September.
Yeah,
it was September.
September.
Yeah.
And it was,
it sucked.
It was fucking brutal.
And I did the dumb shit.
I went out and I drank and um,
I didn't that that's,
you know,
something that's the basis of my advice that I give you guys when you,
men or women when you go through a breakup is just
allow yourself to know that it's gonna suck.
Yes.
It's going to suck.
You're going to come home with the phone isn't going to ring and you're going to
be sitting there trying to put the pieces back together going,
what the fuck did I used to do with all this extra time and
just go through that is the best thing that I can tell you in fucking embrace it
and just know it's going to hurt.
And uh,
that's the best advice I can give you because I did not do that.
The worst thing you want to do was go out,
start booze,
and try to bank somebody else and then go into a fucking rebound relationship.
I did that a couple of times.
It's fucking brutal.
It's not what the fuck you want to do.
So,
uh,
I know we had a couple of questions.
Somebody I keep getting questions about on the open.
Anthony show a Patrice O'Neal and uh,
Kevin Hart talked about this,
this trashing that I took and uh,
it was a long fucking time ago.
I haven't listened to the audio yet.
Uh,
just look it up on Youtube.
I'm sure they have the audio up,
uh,
without even listening to the audio.
Whatever they said is more than truth.
It was an epic 50 fucking minutes trashing that I took.
Um,
what the fuck was the story SD at the comedy cellar.
All right,
how do I call it?
What do I start this?
The Yankees were playing the Braves in the fucking world series and I guess it
was these groups of people from Atlanta wanted to,
uh,
we're going to take this right.
They've taken two buses to Yankee stadium to go to the game and they wanted a
comedian to perform on the bus on the way to the stadium.
All right.
Which obviously is the most nightmare gig ever.
They were going to pay like 500 bucks and give you a world series ticket.
All right,
so the Gig was offered to me like she was like,
who's the two biggest sports fans?
I know we're down here.
So she offered in and actually don't have enough money in the bank where will
actually consider doing this.
So she approached me and Jim Norton about the Gig.
So me and Norton are just talking about it going through,
this is going to be the worst fucking Gig ever,
but you get to go to the world series and we were both thinking about it.
So the next day over 24 hours,
Norton find just goes,
fuck that.
I'm not doing it.
So I was going to do it.
I was like,
fuck it.
It's not going to be that bad a gig.
That's the thing about it.
It wouldn't have been that bad a gig.
I basically was going to get paid to go to a world series game and to get paid
to do what the fuck I was going to do anyways,
which is trashed the Yankees all the way up to Yankee stadium.
That's the only part about the story that's bullshit is them talking about what
a horrific gig it would've been.
It would've been a fucking cake walk compared to those college gigs I did where
they didn't have a fucking microphone and they stand you in a hallway.
It would be a bunch of drunk fans,
excited to see their team that didn't have a shot in fucking hell.
A beat in the Yankees.
And all I was going to do is tell them what a fag Jeter was for fucking 30
minutes,
a half hour fucking set would have been a joke.
All I would have to do is trust the Yankees the whole fucking way up.
I get 500 bucks and I get a world series ticket and the second I get off,
I can screw.
I can leave those guys.
I get to go to a world series game and fucking Yankee Stadium.
So I'm like,
I'm going to fucking do it.
Right.
So I didn't know that Jim had said that he wasn't going to do it.
So we're sitting down there at the table down at the cellar and it starting up,
everybody's giving each other shit.
So I start giving Norton Shit about whatever,
about his chinless face,
uh,
his little ears or whatever,
fucking awful hooded sweatshirt that he was wearing.
And then I got him with a couple of jabs and he felt the overhand right come in
and he needed to stop it and he just goes,
whatever busboy and it was like ef Hutton,
everybody fucking stopped and went,
what,
why did you just call him busboy?
And I immediately was like,
he's going to do it too.
And Somehow Jim got out of it and just,
he literally threw me under the bus and then they found out I was doing the Gig.
And it just so happened that night that all the fucking,
the,
the big boys where there was Patrice Norton was there,
Kevin Hart,
Rich Vos,
Keith Robinson,
right fucking there,
the Tyson Holyfield,
George Foreman,
all of that.
And I'm standing there like fucking a tex Cobb.
And I took a 50 minute,
I took a headlining set,
killing,
standing ovation set of shit for doing that Gig.
And I was still going to do it.
I was still gonna do it even after the fucking trash.
And cause I'm thinking I'm going to the fucking world series.
I don't give a shit,
you know.
And Patrice was trashing me and I didn't give a fuck what he said.
His advice I never would've listened to because Patrice was one of the biggest
pussies when it came to performing hell gigs.
Like when we used to do colleges,
uh,
this guy used to book us on colleges and would be me,
him and Robert Kelly,
or meet him in Norton or whatever.
And this dude never wanted to go on first,
cause first sucks because you've got a warm up the crowd and he never wanted to
go on last because you had to follow the other two x.
He
always wanted to go on second,
any a and then he'd go on second and he would go over his fucking time,
like the selfish country.
And,
uh,
so I was just saying,
yeah,
you know this guy,
this guy fucking a,
this guy retires from comedy every two weeks when he sees a hack kill on stage.
I don't give a fuck what he thinks.
But it was,
it wasn't until the end when he actually looked at me when the trashing was over
and he said,
Bill,
he goes,
I will stand in front of that bus.
Don't do that Gig.
I'll buy you a ticket to the world series.
Don't do that.
And then I was sitting there going like,
wow,
this is actually like,
he's not even joking right now.
He's trying to tell me for the love of God have a little bit of self fucking
worth.
And he,
he shit.
That was the thing.
After a 50 minute trashing isn't as embarrassing as that was,
nothing was worse than the shame of him
telling me that I could actually afford a world series ticket.
At that point,
I wasn't really even thinking that.
So I decided I,
in that moment I decided not to do the Gig,
which I don't think came out on the opiate Anthony show.
They think I did the Gig.
I never did the Gig.
And I actually passed it off to another comedian who was further down the ladder
than I was.
And uh,
he didn't even ask me,
but I always made a promise that I would never say who did the Gig.
And uh,
I don't know.
Next time I go on Opie and Anthony,
I'll talk to the dude who actually did the Gig and see if he wants to call in
and talk about the Gig.
But that's the only,
I haven't listened to the audio yet,
but whatever jokes that they said,
there was some classic ones.
I remember Patrice say,
well,
hey bill,
when they bring you up,
are you going to come out of the bathroom or are you going to walk up up those
little stairs?
That,
and then also me finishing my second.
Oh.
And Hey,
thanks a lot.
And then I sit down in the bus seat and then look over my shoulder and shake
everybody's hands as they go to get off the bus.
Was I going to fucking hold the,
uh,
you know,
the bus intercom thing?
What I do it over that Yada,
Yada,
all that and fit and this will kill me.
They had jokes for 50 fucking minutes.
All that was true,
but I never did the Gig.
I never did the Gig and uh,
and I still maintain,
it wouldn't have been that bad of a fucking Gig.
It wouldn't have been.
What have been a joke bill?
Get on a bus for a half an hour and trashed the Yankees.
Do you think he can do that?
We'll give you 500 bucks in a world series ticket.
Absolutely.
I would've been drinking with them at any time.
I ran out of shit to talk about the Yankees.
He just look out the bus,
hey,
look at the tits on that fucking whore and they'd all go nuts.
All I had to do is support the south in the civil war.
There was so many different ways that I could've done that.
It would've been a fucking cake walk,
a fucking cake walk,
and I didn't end up doing it.
I didn't end up doing it,
which actually was better because the first time I went to a world series ended
up being,
uh,
I went to game two with a 2004,
that boring ass world series.
But it exciting cause we finally won it.
So there you go.
So that,
that is the story.
Yes,
they trashed the shit out of me,
but I never did the Gig.
I was shamed out of doing it and I gave it to another convenient who will remain
nameless.
Actually,
you know what,
here,
let me,
let me do a little cross promotion here.
Uh,
I will reveal the name the next time I do the opiate Anthony show.
If they still give a fuck,
if they still give a shit,
if the story has legs as they say in the business.
So a,
so there you go.
There's that fucking story.
Alright.
And I'll try to remember the name of this podcast in case he gets somebody.
A couple more questions about it and I'll just say refer to the podcast on
December 27th.
Um,
all right,
you two videos of the week.
Um,
these are all going to be on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
You can watch all of these.
The so called white man,
somebody sent a great video of somebody.
The dude didn't have a microphone but he was,
he was talking about all how the white man,
you know,
is fucking with everybody the way he twisted up religion and all that shit,
which is totally true.
But in the end he goes,
cause God is actually a black man.
So basically it's like everything that white people just did.
I am now going to do from my perspective,
which is the one thing that I've learned when I being on the road that everybody
is the same and it includes the bad shit.
You know,
that liberal thought that,
you know,
everybody has to say,
but it's only good shit.
Everybody has the ability to be a scientist,
to be a doctor.
You know,
a fucking teacher.
Everybody has.
Yes,
yes they do.
And they also have the ability to be a fucking CEO at Enron to be a rapist and
to be a fucking serial killer and all the bad shit.
Everything to be a war criminal,
a fucking dictator,
everybody that is not,
that is not an exclusively white thing because white people get blamed for evil.
Like where the only evil ones in the planet,
we are not,
we are just the best at it.
We are the Michael Jordans of evil.
Everybody,
I challenge your race to top my race with the evilness,
but you've got it in you.
You got to know that.
All right?
You got to know that you have it in you the same way you have it in you to be a
doctor or a lawyer or a teacher.
You also have it in you to be a,
a complete fucking sociopath.
Uh,
so there's,
there's,
there's my fucking 2 cents.
All right.
Clumsy report or knocks down,
uh,
I don't know how to say Jenga Tower.
And he wanted this leaning tower of Piza.
Um,
Fva tow rope fail to somebody towing their friend's car down the street with a
rope and it doesn't go that well.
Merry Christmas bitch.
Need I say more Harvard sailing team.
Boys will be girls and on from funny or die drunk history.
And I think that's it.
I think that's it for the podcast.
This has been a very long one.
I Gift Card really quick.
Let me read this.
Uh,
Gift Card Dude.
What is your deal with gift certificates?
This guy right here is the exact reason why I don't like gift certificates.
Would you rather get some shitty sweater or boxer briefs from your aunt or
brother in law or a gift certificate from Amazon or best buy where you could buy
something you actually like,
Hey,
fuck head.
Why don't you not go out and buy a shitty sweater?
A boxer briefs.
See you.
Uncreative comment.
Maybe you should give out a gift card.
That's why I don't like it.
Because you know,
it's like you're out there and you buy somebody a great fucking gift and then
they go,
hey,
you go shop for yourself.
Fuck face.
It's lazy.
That's why.
That's why I don't fucking like it.
I don't mind it if I get,
if we both agree to get each other gift certificates,
I don't mind that when I'm out there actually trying to buy you a fucking cool
as gift and you come up with that,
you just write me a check.
You know,
like I'm some drunk whore going to say your fucking son raped somebody and
you're running for Senate and you need the problem to go away.
That's why I don't like it.
So go fuck yourself.
I'm all right.
Revenge.
I got to read this quickly here.
Um,
which is gonna cause all kinds of problems.
Uh,
all right.
I went to a local junior college,
uh,
wait a second,
I jumped in too far.
Uh,
this may be a more of a story of lashing out then revenge.
I actually think this is a story of revenge and I like this story because this
is eyeballed eyeball even though it was a little off Samuelson here.
Uh,
my senior year I dated a beautiful underclassmen.
She was my first love in,
firstly,
we dated through the summer after graduation I went on to a local junior
college.
Uh,
the next year,
Jesus Christ shop class guy right here.
All right.
Uh,
we were still dating when school started up the next year.
I had a lot of friends that were still in high school and one of my best friends
told me that he started seeing my girlfriend hanging out at school with another
good friend of mine.
Uh,
my girlfriend was acting shady so I knew something was up.
Um,
for years during the football season,
a big group of guys would get together on Sundays and play a game of tackle
football.
Uh,
this guy who was seen with my girlfriend was among the guys that showed up to
play with me.
Dot.
To play with the,
uh,
everybody,
me and this guy,
this other guy,
you name it all names.
I'm trying to skip over the names here.
Me and this other guy would normally play Qb,
so we would be the two to pick teams each week.
Um,
the quarterback on the other team was also a good friend of mine.
The friend of mine,
Paul,
these fucking names here,
the friend of mine who was messing with my girl didn't know that.
I was aware that he and my girl had been flirting at school.
So I asked my buddy,
the QB on the other team to pick this Douche who's messing with my girl and at
some point during the game send them in on a hard five and in I,
I don't know what that is that like a post pad,
I guess it's a crossing pattern and lead them high.
He's basically going over the middle.
He's going to throw them,
throw the ball high and just out of his reach,
leaving this guy completely exposed.
So anyways,
he goes a few plays into the game.
They come out of the huddle and my buddy,
the QB on the other team gives me a look.
He goes,
I called a two one two defense.
Jesus Christ,
this is like the most professional pickup football game ever.
So I bring in the nickel defense.
I had to call a time out because we had too many men on the field.
I call the two one two defense and took the short rides zone.
The ball was snapped and this douche bag who's flirting with my girl came off
the line,
took a hard left and in slow motion,
ran into my zone.
I delay one or two seconds and begin the path to the collision.
My buddy let him perfect.
So he had to pick up a little speed to get to the ball,
any extended,
both arms to the sky.
And of course he's looking back at the quarterback to Jesus Christ.
The second the ball hit his hands,
I bury my shoulder into his stomach.
I grabbed the back of his knees and I pull up and drive them into the ground.
And
now I can't define the word squelch,
but he definitely let out a sound that old that I can only describe as
squelched.
Uh,
yeah,
it really that,
that word makes it sound like you actually hit a really right melon,
the entire field or ruptured with a holy shit.
My little league coach would have given me two stars on my helmet for this
fucking hit.
I felt good about it for about three seconds and the room than the remorse set.
And I feel bad to this day for setting this guy up the way I did.
It took a few minutes for him to get up.
Uh,
but he was fine.
I don't know about Karma,
but a few weeks later,
uh,
this dude that he drilled into the ground was banging his ex girlfriend and I
met my rebound that I dated for the next five years.
She turned out to be the devil herself.
I might not believe in God,
but I've hooked up.
I've looked the devil in her evil eye as I shot a load into her evil cunt.
Jesus Christ.
Um,
I don't think Karma got you.
I think,
uh,
he was going to bang her no matter what.
And I think he got a nice shot in there.
Um,
it was a little cheesy that you had your friends set them up,
but uh,
but fuck him.
That's what he gets.
That's your girl.
He shouldn't have been doing that.
He was wrong.
You were right.
And,
uh,
as far as Karma goes,
I view Karma is like,
uh,
what's that shit where you look at the stars to see if you're going to get a
chicken sandwich that day.
What do you call it?
Is it astrology?
Astronomy is the study of stars.
Astrology.
Yeah.
Like I don't believe in astrology.
You know,
and anybody who does,
you go,
okay,
you believe in it.
I and you just go,
what's your sign?
And I,
and they tell you this sign and then read somebody else's horoscope.
If they're a Gemini,
read a Taurus and Gar.
And how does that pertain to your life?
The big,
okay.
It means
this,
this and this.
And Go.
Yeah,
see that was Taurus.
So there you go.
You can fucking,
this is so vague.
You can attribute it to anything.
Something wonderful is going to happen today.
Just be careful you don't close it off or it won't happen.
So then if something wonderful doesn't happen,
you're then walk while I,
I must've been closed off.
I need to be more open and then they get off Scott free.
Right.
I feel the same way about Karma.
Karma is something that if you,
there's ups and downs in life.
Okay.
And if you just,
you're waiting for something bad to happen,
something bad is going to fucking happen.
No matter how good you are,
something bad's going to fucking happen.
You know,
buy brand new pair of sneakers,
someone's gonna step on them.
You know,
you're like,
well,
hey,
start a fucking,
I starve.
I sponsored a starving child.
I don't fuck around.
I'm a good guy.
Why did somebody step on my sneaker?
Because the world is full of cunts.
It's impossible not to run into him.
You know,
I think Karma exists if you believe in it.
I think if you don't believe in Karma,
like you never really,
you don't really have any bad shit happen to you.
There you go.
That's what I think about comma.
I am an hour and 17 fucking minutes into this podcast.
Ladies and gentlemen.
I think it's time to,
uh,
to end the podcast here.
Uh,
I hope you enjoyed it.
Hope you guys all had a very merry Christmas,
a happy Kwanzaa,
happy Hanukkah.
Or maybe it just said,
fuck it all and I'm going to take a few days off and,
uh,
that is it.
That's the podcast.
Please,
please.
Oh,
Well,
the shows are all sold out,
so go scalp a ticket.
I,
speaking of Jim Norton,
the man who threw me under the bus,
and it took them 10 years to make up for it,
actually made up for it when you put me on down and dirty.
And he hooked me up with OPN.
Anthony.
Um,
but let's say I don't count those,
you know,
cause I'm into astrology.
Uh,
he hooked me up again with this awesome Gig,
uh,
that he does every year at the,
fuck.
I'm going to screw this up down in Atlantic city.
And this year he was like,
you know what,
why should I take it all for myself?
Why don't I share it with some friends?
And I'm doing a show at the,
the,
the fucking casino down there and Atlantic city.
Why don't I know the name of it?
Fucking internet doesn't work on my bedroom,
whatever.
It's fucking sold out anyways,
but it's me,
Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer and David Tell it's going to be a fucking unbelievable night at three
shows.
If you can't make that,
if you didn't get tickets,
it's cause it's already sold out.
Um,
my next Gig is I'm going to be in Dallas,
Texas on the final weekend in January,
the week of the NFL pro bowl.
Uh,
the 27th,
28th,
29th,
I believe.
That weekend I'm going to be at the Improv in Dallas.
I'm sorry,
28,
29 and 30 Improv in Dallas,
Texas.
Please come out.
I got a brand new killer hour stuff.
Uh,
anything else?
Oh,
red sox fans are baseball fans in general.
You should check this out.
Uh,
Steve Gorman from the,
uh,
black Crowes has his own podcast.
Of course,
I don't have the fucking link cause I'm an idiot.
Steve Gorman sports sgs is the name of the podcast.
Great podcast.
He interviews Kevin Euclid and uh,
Kevin Gee,
he just,
he's got a great interview style where he just gets the other person to relax
and he starts talking about just all kinds of cool shit.
Favorite ballparks,
favorite restaurants.
If you're into sports performance enhancing drugs,
Pete rose,
should he be in the hall of fame or not having entourages
um,
team chemistry,
all the shit you want to tell.
And it's great.
It goes on for well over an hour and it's totally fucking entertaining.
Highly recommend that podcast keeps getting better every time I hear it.
And that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to be interviewing Nick Swardson,
uh,
this week for a very special podcast and I am also going to the rose bowl,
the granddaddy of them all on a new year's Day.
And I am going to be stoned fucking sober this year.
I know you guys are all born right now cause you want to hear the happy drunk
stories where I'm sick of being a drunk on that day.
I would like to remember,
like I,
I went to a game and Sanchez played the USC Penn State.
I went to that game and I had never even heard of Sanchez.
That's how drunk I was.
So the thing that I could have been alive,
bullying that guy,
I would've made a different seat.
They still fucking killed the,
uh,
they still kill Penn state.
All right,
whatever.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you.
Have a great week.
Don't take any
shed.
And I go fuck yourself.
[inaudible].